well I'm here in New Mexico publicizing
my book secret Mesa inside los alamos
national laboratory and Los Alamos is
just 30 some miles from santa fe is your
book tour just in New Mexico and where
have you gone within New Mexico well
this is the beginning for me and I
started in Albuquerque and went to Los
Alamos and then after this I don't
really know it's an evolving thing since
your book is about Los Alamos tell us
about what it was like to go to that
town that you wrote about and what the
audience was like well it was really
interesting I have to say I was a little
nervous about it because Los Alamos is a
community and that's been written about
so much and not always kindly or well
there are a lot of really Looney
articles out there about Los Alamos that
have really no connection to reality and
of course people come to the institution
which was the birthplace of the atomic
bomb and has conducted weapons research
for 50 years they come to the
institution with certain prejudices
naturally so the I was nervous to be
propped up in front of these people
speaking at the Bradbury Science Museum
but I was stunned to find that they were
very welcoming very interested and very
supportive actually of the book even
though I was critical in some ways and
and didn't spare any words describing
the kind of community it is but they
were happy that it was fair to them that
it was balanced and that pleased me very
much last night did you get a feel is
that when you were in Los Alamos did you
get a feel for who was in the audience
was it residents that work at Los Alamos
was at people from Santa Fe did you get
any sort of feeling from the questions
they asked it was almost all people from
Los Alamos and it was
wide variety of people young people
working at the laboratory older people
who had been there for most of their
careers all kinds of people men and
women women who was only connection to
the place was that they came there with
their husbands and didn't even
understand what their husbands did in
the beginning that sort of thing lots of
good stories lots of interesting people
we're talking also about your book
secret Mesa inside Los Alamos National
Laboratory tell us from the beginning
what is Los Alamos and why did you
choose to write a book about it well Los
Alamos is the place where the first
atomic bomb was produced it was a huge
research project called the Manhattan
Project and it was a response to the
suspicion that Hitler may have the
technology where by his scientists could
make an atomic weapon so they worked
very hard spent billions of dollars
billions of Ben wartime dollars to
develop one or two weapons to use if
they needed to and Los Alamos was chosen
because it's isolated it was a good
place to keep secrets and then after the
war was over after they used the atomic
weapon as we know the laboratory
continued to thrive there was some
thought that it would be closed but then
that became clear it was needed because
Russia was developing weapons or the
Soviet Union was developing weapons in
any case they've been there all this
time studying and making nuclear weapons
remind us again when was the first
atomic bomb dropped well the United
States is the only country that's ever
used in atomic web
in war and it was in August 1945 where
did that happen well it was first
dropped on Hiroshima Japan and then a
few days later Nagasaki
can you tell us more about the
repercussions of that where their
casualties how many and how did that
affect the war well everything excuse me
everything about that incident is still
questioned and studied and crawled
through by public policy people
scientists everyone the effects of it
resonate to today I mean a few years ago
when we celebrated the 50th anniversary
of that event and the end of World War
two people were still discussing should
the bomb have been used where the
Japanese ready surrender would they have
the rationale for using it was that it
would bring the war to a quick
conclusion and save many lives there
were millions of American soldiers that
were poised to invade Japan to bring
this war to an end and all of those
people might or not all but many of
those people might have lost their lives
if the bomb had not been used now the
other the opposing viewpoint is of
course that it was an immoral act should
never have been done and many Americans
feel as though it shouldn't have been
the united states that did it somehow
laziness in a different category morally
somehow but those things are always
going to be discussed I'm not sure
they'll ever be a conclusion to that
discussion and in terms of casualties
that's not even known for sure in
Hiroshima I believe maybe a hundred
thousand people died something
significant happened soon before that
United States bombers started
firebombing Japanese cities so people
died by the thousands in other Japanese
cities to those who don't understand the
difference between the use of
an atomic weapon and firebombing say
dead is dead doesn't matter how you die
you just die well the critical thing
about atomic weapons is that you can
kill many more people with one airplane
and the density of killing is so
horrible more people per square foot in
Hiroshima died then did in any
firebombed city those are some of the
arguments that are talked about and then
when the Smithsonian was preparing the
Enola Gay exhibit you remember the flap
over that people thought some people
thought Japan was being too softly
treated people thought that it ought to
be told more truthfully we're going to
be discussing this forever I think
remind us again what is the Enola Gay
and what was the controversy over that
exhibit you know lagay was the bomber
that took the weapon and dropped it over
Hiroshima and there was going to be an
exhibit at the Smithsonian and I don't
have a lot of memory about this but just
the way it was written about in terms of
what was done the bomb being dropped it
disgruntled American veterans it made
America look and this by the way this
exhibit didn't actually end up being
this way there was so much controversy
about how it was being presented
American veterans of World War two hated
the thought that Americans would be
portrayed as the evil people in this
conflict I mean in any war evil things
are done on both sides and and people
felt that we owed no apologies to Japan
but they owed apologies to us that was
some of the stuff that was being talked
about it it was good I think that we all
had to think about this that was the
important talking that was being done
during that 50th anniversary in your
book you discuss a lot of what's going
on at Los Alamos today how has Los
Alamos changed from the Cold War period
what were we trying to do at Los Alamos
during the Cold War from 1945 on and now
in the post-cold war world what are they
doing at Los Alamos well during that
Cold War period of course the laboratory
was working on nuclear weapons refining
their art making better and more
efficient weapons in serving their
client the Department of Defense they
were also all that time working on other
science and that's something that people
don't always know about and since the
end of the Cold War they have tried to
find another focus for their technology
however nuclear weapons are still very
important we have a lot of them in our
stockpile and their concern is being a
good steward of those weapons so that
God forbid if they should ever have to
be used they work properly so that the
military has confidence in them and so
that
the natural degradation of materials in
nuclear weapons is understood so that
people can understand how they might
perform that's one whole important area
of research at the laboratory that has
also incidentally stabilized their
budgetary problems after the end of the
Cold War there was a state of flux for
the laboratory not really understanding
what was going to happen and how they
would be involved in national life he
mentioned the Department of Defense
explained to us what department oversees
Los Alamos where do they get their
funding how does that work the
Department of Energy is the overseer for
Los Alamos National Laboratory and all
the other laboratories and the money
comes from the American taxpayer they're
funded by Congress now how did you
research this book did you research it
in Washington did you live in Los Alamos
and what papers did you read and who did
you interview I spend a lot of time in
Los Alamos and I should explain that
this book was meant to be and it's what
I think I ended up with a portrait of
the community and of the laboratory and
portraits of the people who live and
work there and so the most important
part of my research was being there I
spent a lot of time there and I did over
100 formal interviews and many more
informal interviews
and read probably every book that's
available about the history of the
laboratory and well it was a tremendous
research project I can't begin to tell
you how many megabytes of computer disks
of information I have not to mention the
stack of books of transcribed interviews
I have so it's a big project when did
you begin your research and how long did
the book take you to write i started in
1992 started really by visiting their
the first time and it took three or four
years to finish the project where do you
live normally I live in Minnesota which
and that's the first question i usually
get from interviewers is why would
someone from some 1,400 miles away
decide to do a book on a laboratory in
New Mexico and you know first of all I
think there is real merit in accounts
written by people who aren't too close
who don't have a lot of assumptions
lifetime assumptions possibly if you're
from New Mexico about an institution and
beyond that I came here working on a new
story and was immediately fascinated
with the place and wanted to know more
and eventually it became a book tell us
about your background is this your first
book and it sounds like you're a
reporter what is your background um I my
in my past I have been a reporter
science and medical reporter i have
written for newspapers and magazines
and peer reviewed journals and for
science museums and I have a very
background that prepared me to do
something like this where did you go to
college I went to the College of st.
Catherine in st. Paul Minnesota
what did you study there I'm actually
I'm a literature major and then I went
back to school to take science courses
because I decided I wanted to be a
science reporter why well I have read a
lot of good science writers and I think
it's a good thing to do I think it's
needed I enjoy being around research
scientists and doctors and I like the
process of translating difficult
information so that regular people can
understand it and I also think that's
very important where our lives are just
entangled in technology and we benefit
and suffer from technology and I think
everyday folks ought to know what it's
all about because we have to make
decisions tell us about why you called
the book secret Mesa and did you go into
Los Alamos lab yourself and what did you
see well of course I went into the
laboratory and I did go behind the fence
which is what they call secure areas and
I was escorted of course and i called it
secret mesa because it's on this
isolated high plateau on a mesa and it
began as a very secret obviously a very
secret installation and it was closed he
was still a secret installation and a
secret town until the 50s you just
couldn't go visit there it was they have
gates and one of the towers one of the
guard towers is still there on the main
road into town and you had to go through
jump through a few hoops to get into
town so then I think that the beginnings
of the town the Cold War habits of
secrecy the necessity for secrecy still
resonate there it is still a community
that is trying to figure out how to be
more open how to be
giving of information to the public I
think now they want the public to
understand them and appreciate them and
not make knee-jerk responses to their
research which is not just weapons
research that's really important they
feel as though they're painted by a very
broad brush there's research there into
the human genome there's an AIDS
database there that is serving
researchers in aids all over the world
there's so much going on their material
science research that affects our cars
our pop cans you know it affects a lot
of things tell us if you're an average
citizen not a reporter a writer but if
you wanted to go and visit Los Alamos
could you look around or how could you
learn more about Los Alamos well of
course you can go there the first time I
went there I had no clearance I had no
appointments I just walked into town
it's a it's a town with normal
neighborhoods and the laboratory is by
and large fairly open they do like
people to check in with their visitors
center and I didn't do that and as a
result some goofy things happened I was
driving around on the roads up there and
I just stop and take a picture of what i
thought was the Santa Fe National Forest
well it was but it was much more than
that it was laboratory property and
immediately a little runabout vehicles
did a u-turn in the middle of the
highway came and sat beside me until I
drove away didn't say anything to me
just watched and then another time it
happened and then I began to realize
this wasn't just the Santa Fe National
Forest there was something else going on
there and I came to understand then what
that was all about they have a security
force they watch people very carefully
there's more plutonium at
los alamos than anywhere in this country
did you ever see plutonium when you were
there actually I didn't I begged and
pleaded to be allowed to go into ta 55
their plutonium research facility and
then after I finished with the book they
did take reporters through and I've been
promised that next time they do it I get
to go and I really would like to in your
book you you've obviously interests
interviewed a great number of scientists
at the laboratory tell us about some of
the more unusual people in town that you
may have spoken with well townfolk or a
research folk because there are unusual
people and both department either one
whichever you think might be of interest
to the story well I really enjoyed
talking to the weapons folk of course
because they are very interesting and
shed light on very scary and interesting
topics like nuclear terrorism and I
talked to a robotics expert who is just
a crazy man a wild man inventive guy
who's making robots that are independent
he puts them down and lets them figure
out the environment they're in little
robotic ants and other weird things did
you speak to any people who are
anti-nuclear or against the nuclear
plant well of course and there's one
fellow in town he's notorious his name
is it Edward growth us and he refers to
himself as Eduardo de los alamos and
he's very colorful he has a salvage
business in town that is full of old lab
stuff basically he has bought up their
garbage the stuff they don't want
anymore some of it very valuable and and
still usable by people who need
scientific equipment and can't afford
the most
and he has he's a peace activist this is
this is that him this is him in front of
what he refers to was the black hole
which is the place where he keeps all of
his stuff and he is interestingly a
former lab employee and he's lived in
the town since nineteen forty nine and
he stays there even though he hates the
business of the laboratory because as he
said all of my friends are there all of
my enemies are there where else would I
go and he's tolerated which is an
interesting comment on the community I
think they did they're big boys and
girls with big shoulders and they can
take a lot of criticism including from
Eduardo who is kind of like that
eccentric uncle who's kind of a pain in
the ass but everybody puts up with him
because he's part of the family and this
is a very interesting guy you've brought
something with you here today it looks
like a can can you tell us what it is
and the story behind it well this is a
can says organic plutonium and has a
mushroom cloud on it and it's from the
reactors of Los Alamos New Mexico the
home of the atomic bomb well of course
it's not really plutonium that would
that would not be good but it is
something that has I think it's peas or
corn but it's been relabeled by eduardo
de los alamos and he sells it in his
store you know it's like a 79 kid said
canapés that he's selling for 512 it was
I think but the interesting thing is he
sent one of these to President Clinton
nobody laughed I don't think it was
considered a funny thing and a couple of
Secret Service agents showed up at his
door and questioned him thoroughly hours
I think and in the end realized it was
just a publicity stunt and nothing
harmful and and mr. growth has said they
were actually very nice peaceful can I
kind of made friends with them so this
is kind of thing that he does it's fun
as a reporter how do you find someone
like mr. growth asst are you in the town
looking for that kind of character did
you read about him how'd you find that
kind of source it wasn't hard to find
Edgar oh--this he found finds everybody
else there are a lot of articles written
about him I read something in Scientific
American I think he's had television
appearances and all kinds of things he
was the least difficult person to find
there are other people that you have to
be very convincing to get them to talk
to you and when just in terms of the
townspeople I had one woman say to me
what kind of book are you writing I mean
she was really cautious she said we've
been burned so many times you won't get
anybody to talk to you if you don't
prove to them somehow for by force of
will if nothing else that you're
planning to write a balanced piece and
so I was lucky enough that I did that
and got a lot of candid remarks from
people as an author how do you talk to
your sources and convince them that you
are trying to write a balanced account
very carefully very carefully I don't
know you know I don't even know if I can
explain what that is it's something that
you learned to do connect with people on
some level and make them feel that they
can trust you that you're not going to
do wrong by them that you're going to
honor in some way what they do and I
think it's different in a
confrontational interview and an
investigative reporting I wasn't doing
that and also in Los Alamos this is
critically important you have to know
how to speak their language if you if
you don't know the words if you don't
understand at least the most rudimentary
aspects of their technology the window
blinds go down pretty quickly and you
can see it happen and you know you're in
trouble so preparation is an important
part of it
what sticks out in your mind the most is
something that surprised you about Los
Alamos that you found out in the course
of writing this book what was the
biggest surprise to you if there was one
well the biggest surprise just in terms
of you know function in the process of
doing the book was how eager people were
to talk and tell their story and how
much they could tell they weren't as
secretive as I thought they'd be I mean
there's a lot of that still and there
are a lot of things that they're very
careful not to talk about they're good
at it but I also in terms of the things
i learned i was surprised at how
involved the laboratory is encounter
proliferation how involved they are in
intelligence in terms of what's going on
now the proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction and i heard stories from
them that just scared the willies out of
me i mean it's it's scary stuff this
terrorism business so would you say
these stories were about Russians or are
the scary stories more about other
countries these days well the scary
stories at least what scared me was the
ease with which people with not good
intentions may be able to get their
hands on materials that can cause a big
mess you know either by contamination
with radioactive products or god forbid
carry off a weapon and we saw in the
news not long ago that Russian that
Russia could not account for a large
number of suitcase size nuclear weapons
and that was something that they had
talked about it was Talan
when I was visiting their years you know
several years ago the potential for that
there are weapons that are very
destructive and very small and as one
guy told me he said you could drive one
inch of New York in an old Corvair you
know that's what that's what frightened
me most of all tell us a little bit
about Los Alamos and public opinion in
your book you talk a little bit about
the radiation experiments and how that
information was released to the public
how do you think that is still unfolding
today with the radiation experiments and
when were they well in terms of the
radiation experiments we do sees stories
once in a while but I think that was the
blip on the public consciousness that
now that's over there's other stuff I
suppose to think about but it's part of
a continuing problem i think that the
public doesn't trust weapons scientists
surprise i mean i don't think they trust
government scientists people don't trust
the government frankly and so it's
difficult for people in our institutions
our scientific institutions or
governmental institutions to to get
people to really trust them and for the
laboratory this is going to be a problem
for a while I think just in terms of
talking about materials or or their work
I mean everyone is always saying they're
they're designing new weapons aren't
they they're not supposed to be of
course well no maybe they are i don't
know but they're never going to convince
the public that they aren't who do you
hope reads this book secret mesa when
you were writing it did you have a
certain reader in mind well i think it
could be interesting to a lot of people
anyone who grew up during the Cold War
would certainly be able to hook into
this because we all grew up with that
terror that thought that it could all be
over and to know where a lot of the
technology comes from could be
interesting for people who lived through
World War two and understood at the end
what brought it to a conclusion it might
be interesting to them it's written so
that it's accessible to anyone who has
any interest in technology in government
science in history and also in good
stories I mean there's some really
interesting people in that town and I
got to talk to quite a few of them so if
nothing else it's I think it's a good
read have you received any criticism
from anyone on on any side of the
nuclear industry over this book not not
from people in the industry no one
gentleman last night wished that I had
written more about the other science at
the laboratory and I do too but I really
think I wrote about the things that are
most worrisome to everyday Americans so
I had to focus and that's what I did
maybe there's another book in all of
that I don't know that was exactly what
I was thinking now that you've spent so
many years on this book and it's
published and you're out talking about
it have you had a chance to think about
your next book and what might that be
about well I'm not sure I'm not sure yet
I'm very interested in the idea of
storing nuclear or chemical wastes on
Indian lands and so I've been doing some
research about that I don't have a book
book contract in that
that yet I would like to do more about
los alamos national laboratory or about
the wider community we'll just have to
see there's so much that can be written
it's it's a pretty deep well how do you
think this book will sell and who's your
publisher by the way the publisher is
john wiley & sons and i don't know how
it will sell i mean that's that's a good
question you never know and then this is
what I hear from my editor and from
people in my publisher you just don't
know how to call it sometimes what will
interest people what will pique their
interest it's it's a it's a little magic
well we thank you Joe and schreier for
spending some time with us to talk about
your new book secret Mesa inside los
alamos national laboratory thank you